woke CEOs once again thinking they know
best when it comes to what's good for
society the guy who runs personal
hygiene brand at Unilever big fan says
anyone who isn't on the woke train is
destroying the world
stating the obvious that we have an
emergency we have a climate emergency is
becoming an unpopular thing to do this
anti-sustainability backlash this
anti-walk backlash
is incredibly dangerous for the world
and the first thing that Unilever will
do is we will not back down on this
agenda despite these populist
accusations
and it doesn't stop there woke companies
are stealing a page from Biden's covid
Playbook call anything a crisis to get
cash watch
at first recognize it's a crisis
and you know just how we found there's a
14 or 17 trillion for covid the money
must be there somewhere
money must be there somewhere
proclimates we need more trees we can
get more money ESG forces companies to
prioritize political causes over their
shareholders that's what it does and
there's a lot of
commentary now about the E part of ESG
the environmental part but I think the s
the social part is also really
interesting because for example if a
company does not take doesn't allow for
reimbursement of travel for an abortion
the employees at that company might
declare it a hostile work environment
and then in the ESG guidelines you can
get docked and that hurts the company or
you're like Delta Airlines and you take
a ridiculous position about the Georgia
voting law because you don't want to get
docked even despite the facts so I think
that you there's a lot to be said here
about investing Import in a in a way
that protects the environment and is
good for the uh
uh well I guess the shareholders but
the whole idea of the social notion of
it and the environmental piece of it is
really I think leading us down a path
where you have corporations and that
will be speaking for the left even if
they don't want to did my people at
Delta do something we don't like
um
no Delta's good company
who's the question going to what's going
on okay good all right look ready here's
the bottom line companies should be
concerned about their bottom line they
have a fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders to their bottom line and
all this other stuff they may feel good
about it it has nothing to do with the
bottom line so don't interfere with my
ability to make money I'm not going to
buy any stock in your company I'm not
even going to buy your products anymore
with this won't nonsense and the perfect
example is Disney's public approval
plummeted from 77 to 33 percent when
they decided to get involved in the
don't say gay law in uh in Florida now
why why that's none of their business it
has nothing to do with their company
because they let a few employees try to
determine what the company's going to do
in a social and Environmental Way
government is about the bottom line and
nothing else they make lever 2000 I hear
the soap it's the last time I used
levers 2000. I'm going to vote with my
personal hygiene products
so when it's interesting to me when
Republicans don't like something that
goes about talking about careful no no
you you you call it woke when Democrats
don't like something that's being said
or that's being done they want to cancel
it we all got to take a breath here and
take take a step back because in the
context the way we talk about these
things both Elon Musk and Steve Jobs who
I think are the greatest uh Visionaries
business Visionaries of my lifetime
would have probably been called woke or
been attempted to cancel musk wanted to
make electric cars and I I differ with
Dana a little different point of view
about ESG about the environmental and
social and governance piece I don't
think it's all all political I think
there's something to be said for but
under your analysis you to call musk
woke you might have called Steve because
musk said we're going to take the
combustible engine and make it obsolete
we're going to do something different
I know but it's still this guy's saying
look I'm not here but I'm just saying
look we oh yeah
got to take a step back here jobs who
revolutionized the way we consume buy
and consume groceries music other
entertainment content he might have been
called woke he might have been he might
have been someone might have tried to
cancel him because they didn't like the
how easy or how free it might have been
all I'm saying is some people deserve to
be called woke some people deserve to be
canceled but before we quickly and just
reflexively do it I think we ought to
just take a breath everybody Democrats
Republicans Independents alike and
assess things without the political lens
that I think we all seem to conveniently
and reflexively do Elon Musk wants to
start a company for electric cars he
should be able to do it he is not he's
the richest man he's not taking a
company and changing it go ahead the
important thing here is to Define what
we're talking about and Dana got to it
but I just want to expand it because
people at home probably don't know what
ESG is right it stands for environment
social governance issues and it is it's
a it's a corporate policy that's being
instituted in some companies mainly
large companies because they can they
can shoulder the burden that small
companies can't this policy exists
independent of its shareholders and its
customers it actually gets between them
right it shifts the attention onto
social justice and climate issue again
to you point putting politics over
profits so if I were a shareholder I
would be livid I would sell my stock
immediately I would only invest in
companies that do not participate in
this there's another little uglier part
going here here Unilever it's like a
really really wealthy person who brags
about giving to charity even though it's
a tiny percentage they never give enough
to feel it so what they're asking and
demanding of other companies they can't
do so only so all these big giant
companies they are virtue signaling
they're saying look how good we are we
care about social issues and we can't
they're only doing it to cover their
asses and we know that that's all this
that's all the woke corporate policy is
is to keep the activism out of their
front and backyard this is a virtue
signal just like a super expensive
graduate degree is for a wealthy person
a wealthy dumb person who wants to buy a
degree so they look super smart that's
all this is this makes them look
compassionate that's it's like a
six-figure liberal arts degree that a
rich kid gets and then they get their
debt canceled and we end up paying
that's what ESG is ESG is simply a
corporate policy that hurts the
shareholder and the customer don't
forget that because they don't want you
to know that they want you to remain
confused can I add one thing so and then
you get a score so your company gets a
score and they'll put that on their
LinkedIn right like so for younger
employees that want to come work at the
company and say well our ESG score is a
98 but oh wow wow yeah they must be
amazing it's a virtue signal yes it's a
pure virtue I'm sure Fox isn't doing
this right Jesse I hope not
because if they are today I changed my
mind this is the greatest thing are you
saying we have to give so much to
charity that it hurts yes
I never heard that before
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now